- Sorry if this book report's
not very good.
I've been up late
working hard on it,
but then also "School Ties"
came on,
and that's one of
my favorite movies,
which is surprising,
'cause I don't like
anything school-related, but
I love Jewish-themed movies.
- No, that's okay.
- Why are you interrupting
the book report?
- Oh, I didn't realize you...
Are you reading that
off the page?
- Yes!
- Oh. Sorry.
It was so conversational,
I thought we were just talking.
- Okay, well now I lost
my frickin' spot.
- I'm sorry.
- Just let me...
All flustered now.
[clears throat]
I did my book report on
"Fear and Loathing
in Las Vegas."
I liked it slash it was
confusing as [bleep].
The book starts
with Raoul Duke
behind the wheel
of a convertible.
[eagle screeches]
He realizes the drugs he took
earlier are kicking in.
- They're kicking in,
the drugs, yes?
- [garbled mumbling]
- Next to him sits
his 300-pound attorney,
Dr. Gonzo,
aka The Fat Samoan.
- [mumbles]
- They were headed
to Vegas from L.A.
- Let's go to Vegas.
- And there were bats
and stuff.
- I see two more.
- I see bats.
- It's real. It's real.
- They're on their way
to Vegas,
but they got derailed
because Lenny is like,
"Curley, what's up
with your hand?"
- I like to keep my hand
nice and soft
so I can touch my girlfriend.
Aw, that feels gross.
Wait, who's Lennie?
- Me--sometimes, uh,
Raoul Duke
calls himself Lennie.
- Got it.
- So they took off.
- This plane's going fast.
- I don't think planes
were invented yet.
- They continued their journey.
- Cow, cow, cow, cow.
- That's not a cow.
That's a tire.
- It was much easier
for them to get to Vegas
by taking the good ol'
Mississippi River.
- We gotta catch that
riverboat.
- I agree with you.
- You catch anything?
- Just this minnow.
Uh-oh.
You want it?
- Nice minnow!
- And by that time, Dr. Gonzo
was a free man.
- Gene.
- Whoosh.
- Gene!
- Sup?
- Okay.
Gimme that.
- And get off my desk.
- Jeez. Demanding.
Any questions?
You with the stupid glasses
in the front?
- How many of the books
that I gave you did you read?
'Cause it feels like you read
parts of all of them
without noticing
they were different,
and wove them into one story.
- Okay, CSI Miami,
if you say so.
Or--any of the CSI's
would work.
- Didn't you notice that
the names kept changing?
- Yeah, but I thought
they were, like, nicknames.
Like, how some people call me
"Genie" or "Goosetits."
Really wish that one
would go away.
- How is that
even possible?
- Oh, guys said that my tits
looked like goose beaks.